Lola and Sean how are y'all doing good
how are you I love your outfit that's so
sick
thank you I like purposely wore this for
y'all so thank you
well yeah I gotta I gotta drop right
into this
um it was an incredible season I got the
chance to watch the full thing and y'all
are just spectacular
you're welcome so what can you know fans
expect from season two I know what
goodness they're getting maybe you could
give us like a little teaser
I think that fans can expect a lot of uh
a lot of growth individual growth from
the characters especially since from
where we last uh left them in season one
and also growth in their relationships
things have definitely
changed as they do over time
um I think all the characters are in
very different head spaces when season
two picks up
um and it's really interesting to see
their journey to sort of
um
I think getting back to some
yeah trying to find some of them that
get get some of the magic back that that
maybe they don't have as much of anymore
I think they're like
yeah you said it thank you
the magic well um you know I gotta ask
I'm just gonna throw a little like
t-swifty moment in here for a second
Lola because we saw that you went uh to
this Taylor Swift's eras tour
um what was your reaction when you found
out that August would play in season two
teaser trailer I
found out the morning that the teaser
was posted like probably an hour before
so I had no idea and I just kind of
opened my email and opened this teaser
and I was like
oh because I mean I think also last year
that
this love being part of the trailer and
the teaser was so perfect and I was like
what are they gonna do this year how are
they going to top it I don't know I mean
elevated it was just so so I mean Jenny
has such a as a wonderful intelligent
mind because it was so perfect and the
version of August that's in the teaser
is so beautiful and so cinematic and
special and I was very excited when I
when I found out
listen I can only imagine I can only
imagine and seeing it IRL well I gotta
talk sorry I gotta talk quickly about
the Dynamics between all of y'all we're
seeing belly and Stephen belly and
Conrad Stephen and Taylor just to name a
few you know why was it so important to
Showcase all of these different Journeys
and and the characters
you know the journeys that these
characters go on yeah I mean I think
it's important for as these characters
uh
grow in their own Journey it's important
to see how their paths intersect and
then how like what happens if a person
is
a lot farther along their own path to
something and whatever that means and
they intersect and it's like I think
there's there's Beautiful Moments with
the belly and Stephen where it's like
these are two people that are clearly on
their own journeys of of different
Journeys yeah very different journeys of
self-discovery but every now and again
they will cross and whether it's just a
little nudge you know or like a a couple
lines here and there it's a it's a
gentle reminder that um they are all
there for each other and they will
continue to be there for each other in a
way that not a lot of other people can
be
um you know and yeah I think you see
also all these characters one thing
that's been so special about the show is
that there's so many different
characters to relate to and anyone can
sort of find someone to relate to and a
lot of them handle
different situations and dealing with
different emotions very differently so
if you can't relate to one one way that
someone's handling something there's
someone else I think
to relate to which is really really
special It Doesn't Remind yourself dude
kids man you know some of the stuff
they'd be going through I'm like because
I remember reading so much and I'm like
why does belly do that why does Stephen
do that why does karma do that and I'm
like oh my God they're 17. like oh my
god of course you know absolutely well
that's so special and you're right there
are so many relatable characters and so
many strong messages so I'm really
excited for everyone to see season two
so thank you so much thank you thank you